The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MITOpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN OPPENHEIM: Hi.
So it turns out that
you guys missed out
on some of the best parts
of these lectures, which
is all the kibitzing that
goes on in back of the cameras
just before they get started.
Well, in the last lecture,
we stressed the equivalence
of finite length and
periodic sequences.
In particular, as
hopefully you recall,
we talked about a finite
length sequence, x of n,
which was of length
capital N. In other words,
it's equal to 0, except in the
range 0 to capital N minus 1.
We stressed also the fact that
if the sequence is considered
a finite length
capital N, then it
can also be considered of
longer length than that,
or equivalently the statement
that it's a finite length
doesn't imply that some of the
values in the interval 0 to N
minus 1 can't also be 0.
In relating a finite
length sequence
to a periodic sequence, we
generated a periodic sequence,
x tilde of n, by simply
repeating the finite length
sequence over and over again
with a period of capital
N. That is x of n was added to
itself, shifted by capital N,
shifted by 2 capital N,
shifted by 3 capital N.
And because of the fact
that it's a finite length,
there is no interference
between each
of these individual
replicas of x of n.
The result then is
a periodic sequence,
one period of which corresponds
to the finite length sequence.
Well, we'll have
occasion frequently
to refer to this
periodic sequence
in describing the
finite length sequence.
And consequently it's
convenient to use
a slightly different
notation than the summation
that we've been using.
In particular, we
can rewrite this
as the periodic
sequence, x tilde
of n, equal to x of
n modulo capital N.
That is x of n modulo capital
N, in other words, the argument
of x of n is little n taken
modulo capital N. Another way
of writing that notationally
which is convenient,
is just to simply express
that as a double parentheses
with a subscript
capital N, so that this
means x of n, the argument
n, taken modulo capital N.
So, you can see then
that as little n varies
over the interval 0
to capital N minus 1,
we see the finite length
sequence x of n as little n
is equal to capital N. Capital
N taken modulo, capital N is 0.
So we'll see x of 0 back again.
And as little n varies
in the range capital N
to 2 capital N minus 1.
That argument taken
modulo N again
repeats the values of x
of n the range n equals 0
to capital N minus 1.
Expressing it this way or
equivalently expressing it
this way, as I stressed before
in the previous lecture,
corresponds to taking the
finite length sequence, x of n,
and simply wrapping it
around the circumference
of a cylinder.
As we run around the
circumference of the cylinder,
we see x of n repeated
over and over again.
Likewise, we were able to
get back to the finite length
sequence from the
periodic sequence
by simply multiplying by
a rectangular sequence,
in other words extracting
a single period.
A single period of
the periodic sequence
corresponds to the finite length
sequence that we began with.
In the last lecture we then
introduced the discrete Fourier
series of x tilde of n,
and the discrete Fourier
series coefficients we denoted
as capital X tilde of k,
and chose to interpret
them, as you recall,
as a periodic sequence, periodic
in k with a period of capital
N. The discrete Fourier
series representation, just
to summarize it
again for you, we've
rewritten here that is a
sum of complex exponentials
harmonically related
generate x tilde of n.
And the Fourier series
coefficients, capital X tilde
of k were given by
this expression.
And I stress again
the fact that we
chose to interpret the
Fourier series coefficients
as a periodic sequence.
And it didn't particularly
matter, because in any case
we only use a single
period of that
in constructing the periodic
sequence, x tilde of n.
Now in this lecture,
what we'd like to do
is apply the idea of
the discrete Fourier
series and the similarity
or basically the equivalence
of finite length and
periodic sequences
to a Fourier series
representation of finite length
sequences.
And basically the
idea is that we
can convert the
finite length sequence
to a periodic sequence.
We've seen how to do that,
and go back and forth.
Generate a Fourier series
representation for that,
and then simply interpret the
Fourier series coefficients
as what we'll call the
discrete Fourier transform
of the finite length sequence.
So, the discrete
Fourier transform then
is given by the
sum from n equals 0
to capital N minus
1 of x of n times
w sub capital N to the nk,
corresponding to the fact
that if we generate a
periodic sequence from x of n,
we can recognize that in this
summation for the Fourier
series coefficients,
in fact, we only
use one period of x
tilde of n anyway.
So that we could simply replace
in here x tilde of n by x of n.
And of course,
since the summation
runs from 0 to
capital N minus 1,
we can't tell the difference.
This then is by definition
the discrete Fourier transform
of the finite length
sequence, x of n.
And it is denoted by x of k.
It corresponds to the
Fourier series coefficients
of the periodic equivalent
sequence for x of n,
except that it is
useful to maintain
the duality between the time
domain and frequency domain
by interpreting the
Fourier transform,
the discrete Fourier transform
to be a finite length
sequence, since the sequence
that we're computing
the Fourier transform
from likewise
starts as a finite
length sequence.
Well, that's straightforward.
It just simply involves taking
the Fourier series coefficients
for k in the range 0
to capital N minus 1,
and simply setting them
to 0 outside that range.
In other words, the
discrete Fourier transform,
x of k of a finite
length sequence x of n,
is equal to the Fourier
series coefficients
of the periodic
equivalent of x of n
multiplied by a
rectangular sequence
to extract a single period.
We can likewise then get the
Fourier series coefficients
from the discrete Fourier
transform, x of k,
by simply periodically
repeating x
of k with a period of capital
N. Or equivalently, we
can write that the Fourier
series coefficients, x tilde
of k, are equal to the discrete
Fourier transform values
with the argument taken modulo
capital N. This corresponds
to simply periodically
repeating capital X of k,
like wrapping capital X of
k around the circumference
of a cylinder, running around
the circumference again
and again.
And what we see are the
Fourier series coefficients.
Now perhaps this sounds a
little involved or intricate.
The idea is really very simple.
It just simply is that the
discrete Fourier transform
corresponds to
the Fourier series
coefficients for the periodic
equivalent of the finite length
sequence.
And to maintain the
duality, in this case,
we choose to simply extract one
period of the Fourier series
coefficients so that now we
have a finite length sequence.
Its discrete Fourier transform
is likewise a finite length
sequence.
And the properties of the
discrete Fourier transform,
as we'll see, the
differences in the properties
between this and the
Fourier transforms
we've talked about in previous
lectures are related very
closely to the implied
periodicity in the sequence
or in the discrete
Fourier transform.
Before discussing
the properties,
however, it's useful to relate
the discrete Fourier transform
to the Z transform, as we've
talked about it previously.
In particular, here we
have the Fourier transform,
the discrete Fourier transform
relationship, capital X of k
is the sum from n equals
capital N minus 1 of x of n,
w sub N to the nk.
Although that has to be
multiplied by R sub n of k
to extract a single period.
The inverse discrete Fourier
transform relationship
then is the inverse
Fourier series relationship
1 over capital N the sum
x sub k w sub of capital
N to the minus nk.
And again, since we're
no longer talking
about a periodic sequence,
it's necessary to extract
one period, this multiplied
by R sub capital N of n.
On the other hand,
the Z transform
of the finite length sequence
is the sum of x of n times
z to the minus n.
In general, of course,
the sum running
from minus infinity
to plus infinity,
but because this is a
finite length sequence,
this is a sum from n equals
0 to capital N minus 1,
because of the fact
that the sequence x of n
is 0 outside the range n equals
zero to capital N minus 1.
Well, to relate the Z transform
to the discrete Fourier
transform, we simply need
to compare this expression
with this expression.
And what we see,
ignoring for a moment
the capital R sub N of k,
that these two expressions are
equal if we pick z equal to w
sub capital N to the minus k.
So the discrete Fourier
transform coefficients
are equal to the
Z transform, if we
choose z equal to w sub
capital N to the minus k,
and look at this for
values of k equal to 0,
1, up through capital N minus 1.
What that says then, is that
the discrete Fourier transform
corresponds to samples
of the Z transform;
and where are those samples?
Well, those samples
are on the unit circle.
Because the magnitude
of w is equal to 1.
And for example, if we
chose the case were capital
N was equal to 8, then we would
find that the discrete Fourier
transform coefficients fall
at points on the unit circle,
equally spaced in angle with
eight points around the unit
circle; 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
I did it right.
So these are equally-spaced
points around the unit circle.
For capital N equal to 8, then
the discrete Fourier transform
corresponds to sampling the
Z transform at these eight
points.
And then the only effect that
this capital R sub N of k
has is that it requires
that we interpret this
as a finite length sequence,
the set of eight values,
rather than running around,
and around, and around the unit
circle over and over again.
So, we have then the
discrete Fourier transform.
We have the notion that the
discrete Fourier transform
really is nothing different.
It's exactly the same as
the discrete Fourier series,
except that it's one period
of a discrete Fourier
series extracted.
And furthermore, it
corresponds to sampling
the Z transform at
equally-spaced points
around the unit circle.
Apparently because of the
fact that the sequence
is finite length, from
that set of samples
we're able to get back
exactly the sequence x of n.
That isn't obviously
true, in general.
If we had an arbitrary
x of n, and we
sampled a Z transform
around the unit circle,
in general we wouldn't be
able to get x of n back again.
But if x of n is
a finite length,
then we are able
to obtain x of n
from the samples
of its Z transform.
OK.
Well, I'd like now
to look at some
of the properties of the
discrete Fourier transform.
Again, there are
lots of properties
that we can talk about.
I'll focus on a
few, and primarily
what I want to focus
on is the difference
between the properties for
the discrete Fourier transform
and the properties for
the Fourier transform
or the Z transform as we
have been talking about them
over the last several lectures.
Well, let's look first of
all at the shifting property.
And let me stress that
all of the properties,
as we go through them,
as we present them
for the discrete
Fourier transform,
will relate to the
corresponding property
for the periodic equivalent
of the finite length sequence.
So when we want to ask what
happens to the discrete Fourier
transform when we do such
and such to the sequence,
the basic idea that
basically what we want to ask
is what happens to the
Fourier series coefficients
for the periodic equivalent of
that finite length sequence.
All right.
Let's talk about the
shifting property.
We have a sequence, x of n.
It has a discrete Fourier
transform capital X of k.
And then we have the
periodic equivalent
of x of n, x tilde of n.
And it has a discrete
Fourier series coefficients,
which are the periodic extension
of the discrete Fourier
transform.
Well, the shifting property
that we want to introduce then
corresponds to the
finite length sequence
which is implied by shifting
the periodic sequence, x tilde
of n.
We know that if we shift the
periodic sequence, x tilde
of n plus m, the Fourier
series coefficients
that we get are x
tilde of k multiplied
by a complex exponential w
sub capital N to the minus km.
So the shifting property that
we want to introduce then
for the discrete
Fourier transform,
corresponds to extracting
shifting x of n in such a way
that it corresponds
to extracting
one period of the shifted
periodic sequence, x
tilde of n.
If we do that, if we extract
one period of x1 tilde of n
to get a finite
length sequence back,
then we get a discrete
Fourier transform,
which corresponds to
extracting one period
of this periodic sequence.
And that then is simply the
original discrete Fourier
transform capital X of k
multiplied again by w sub
capital N to the minus km.
Now this shifting that
we're talking about
is a little different
than the kind
of shifting that we've been
doing normally in the Fourier
transform and Z transform.
And it has to be.
Because we're talking
about a sequence
that's a finite length.
That is it's 0 outside the
range, 0 to capital N minus 1.
And if we just simply shift
that sequence linearly,
then we're going to end up with
a sequence that no longer is 0
outside the range 0
to capital N minus 1.
So there's a slightly
different kind
of shifting that
we're talking about.
It's referred to as
a circular shift.
and I'd like to illustrate what
that shifting corresponds to
by referring to one
of the view graphs.
Here I have a sequence, x of
n, which is a finite length.
So it's nonzero only in the
region of the blue values.
And to generate the shifted,
quote, "shifted" version
of x of n, we first generated
the periodic sequence,
x tilde of n.
So this is the periodic
replica or equivalent
of this finite length sequence.
So we simply have this
period repeated over here,
repeated here, repeated
there, et cetera.
It was this sequence
that we shift.
So for example, if we shifted
to the left by two values,
we then have this periodic
sequence shifted to the left
by two values.
But to recover, to extract one
period again in the range 0
to capital N minus 1, we
want to extract this period
of this periodic sequence.
That's what the function
capital R sub capital N of n
does for us.
And the result then is this one
period extracted, and the rest
of the sequence, 0.
Now, we could of course, when
we go through this shifting,
carry ourselves through
all of these steps.
But there's a more
straightforward way
to look at how you get
this sequence directly
from this one.
You can see that we
could have interpreted
the change from here to here,
either by linearly shifting
this sequence or
by taking each one
of the periods in this sequence
and circularly shifting.
As this shifts to the
left, taking points
as they drop out of this
period and recirculating them
around to the beginning
of the period,
or to the side of the period.
Well, you can see that that's
in essence, what we got here.
And in fact, it's in
essence, what we get here.
This corresponds not to
a linear shift of x of n,
but to a circular
shift of x of n.
As we shift this sequence
to the left by two
values, instead of just simply
having these points drop off
the end of this period
from 0 to n minus 1,
we wrap them around
to the other side
so that they come
in over here instead
of wrapping around there.
Now one way to look at
this is to think of x of n,
again as we've
been trying to do,
wrapped around the
circumference of a cylinder.
And what we've done
in the kind of shift
that we're talking
about here, is
just simply rotated the cylinder
by two points, rather than
the usual kind of
linear shift where
we have the sequence stretched
out in a straight line
and we shift the
sequence linearly.
Here we have a circular shift.
Think of the sequence wrapped
around the circumference
of a cylinder, and the cylinder
just rotated by two points
so that the result is that the
two points that are shifted out
of this window between
0 and n minus 1
get shifted in from
the other side.
Notationally a way to say that
is as I've done here, really
what this expression
corresponds to is
that we started with x of n.
We formed the periodic
replica of that
using the modular
notation that we
introduced at the
beginning of the lecture.
Shift that by two points, and
then extract a single period.
So this is a long way--
well I guess it's really
a short way of going
through all these steps.
But it's the idea and not
the mathematical formalism
that's important.
Think of this as a circular
shift of this finite length
sequence inside the interval
0 to capital N minus 1.
OK.
So this then is our
shifting property.
I've rewritten it in a
slightly different way here,
corresponding to using the
modular sort of notation.
That is the statement is that
a circular shift of x of n--
and that's what all this means
is just simply a circular
shift--
has as its discrete
Fourier transform
the original discrete
Fourier transform multiplied
by this complex exponential.
Because of the fact
that we've interpreted
the discrete Fourier transform
as a finite length sequence,
we have again a duality
between the time domain
and the frequency domain.
In particular, if we
apply a circular shift
to the discrete Fourier
transform values,
the resulting finite
length sequence
is the original finite
length sequence multiplied
by a complex exponential.
Well, the details of the algebra
involved in working this out
aren't important right now.
You'll have plenty
of opportunity
to look at those at your
leisure in the text,
also to work some of
this in the study guide.
The important concept right now,
the important thing to cement,
is the notion of a circular
shift of a finite length
sequence.
And think of it as the
finite length sequence
as it shifts, points that
come outside the interval 0
to capital N minus
1, wrap around
and come in on the other side.
Now we also have
symmetry properties
for the discrete Fourier
transform, which are basically
a consequence of the
symmetry properties
for the discrete Fourier series.
I'll remind you that
for the discrete Fourier
series, for a periodic
sequence that's real,
we had the symmetry
property that
said that the real part of the
Fourier series coefficients
are even.
And we wrote that
in a couple of ways.
One of which was to
state that x sub R of k
is equal to x sub R
of capital N minus k.
And the imaginary part of the
Fourier series coefficients
are odd.
That is they're equal to minus
x sub I of capital N minus k.
Well, the discrete
Fourier transform
is one period of the
discrete Fourier series.
And consequently, this
implies the same type
of symmetry properties for the
discrete Fourier transform,
keeping in mind again that we
want to relate these properties
just to a single period.
So we have the discrete
Fourier transform.
Again, we'll assume
that x of n is real.
And the statement then, implied
by simply extracting one period
out of the discrete
Fourier series,
is that the real part of the
discrete Fourier transform
coefficients are equal to
one period extracted out
of the periodic sequence,
which is x sub R of N minus k,
repeated over and over again.
Periodically that's what
the modular notation
did for us, one period
extracted out of that
that's what this rectangular
window does for us.
And we have a similar
type of statement
about the imaginary part.
This is basically
a statement that
says that the real part is even,
if we interpret even correctly.
And the imaginary part is odd,
if we interpret odd correctly.
And in particular,
the interpretation
is a little different
than the way
we've been talking about
even and odd sequences.
Well, to see what
this expression means,
it looks a little involved.
It's got some
modular things in it,
and multiplying by a
rectangular window.
But that's mainly
notational formalism.
And what these two
expressions are saying
are very straightforward.
Let's look, for example,
at what this implies for k
equal to 0 or for k equal to 1.
For k equal to 0, we have x sub
R of capital N modulo capital
N, or equivalently up here
we have capital X sub R of 0
is X sub R of N minus 0 modulo
capital N times R sub N of 0.
Well, R sub N of 0,
according to the way
that we've defined this
rectangular window, is unity.
And what is all this equal to?
Well, it's capital N modulo
capital N, which is 0.
In other words,
this argument at 0,
this simply is a
trivial statement
that says that X Sub R of
0 is equal to X sub R of 0.
And that really doesn't
tell us too much.
For k equal to 1, we
add that X sub R of 1
is X sub R of capital N
minus 1 modulo capital
N times R sub capital N of 1.
This again is unity.
And since capital N
minus 1 is in the range 0
to capital N minus 1
that taken, modulo N
is just simply X sub R
of capital N minus 1.
So what this says is X sub R
of 0 is equal to X sub R of 0.
So as X sub R of 1 is equal
to X sub R of N minus 1.
And if we repeated this, we'd
find X sub R of 2 equal to X
sub R of N minus 2.
And that's in the context
of the discrete Fourier
transform, what we mean by the
Fourier transform being even.
So as an example,
here we have what
can correspond to a real part.
And we have X sub R of k.
We have X sub R of 1 equal to
X sub R of capital N minus 1.
Well, that says that this
value is equal to that value.
X sub R of 2 equal to
X sub R of N minus 2.
That says that this value
is equal to that value.
And likewise this value
is equal to this one.
This one is equal to
that one, et cetera.
In a similar way, we have
a statement that tells us
that the imaginary part is
odd in exactly the same sense.
In other words that
there's a symmetry
as we look at the imaginary
part coming in from both sides
of the sequence.
Incidentally, I've
indicated here
by a dotted line
what would correspond
to the periodic extension
of this set of DFT values.
In other words, this would be
this one repeated over again.
And if we were thinking of
the discrete Fourier series,
this would just be
periodic replicas.
Although in fact,
the discrete Fourier
transform, since
we've interpreted it
as a finite length sequence,
the discrete Fourier transform
would have 0 values
on both ends of this.
All right.
So the corresponding symmetry
for the imaginary part
says that if we look at the
imaginary part at n equals 1,
then that's equal to minus
the imaginary part at capital
N minus 1.
If we look at the imaginary
part at n equals 2,
then that's equal to
minus the imaginary part
at capital N minus 2.
In other words, there
is an antisymmetry
as we look at the
imaginary part coming
in from both ends of the period.
So that's the kind of
evenness and oddness
that we're talking
about when we talk
about the symmetry properties
for the discrete Fourier
transform.
In other words, it's an
even function in the sense
that as we come in from the
two ends, we see a symmetry.
The real part is even.
The imaginary part
is odd, in the sense
that we see an antisymmetry.
As we come in from the
two ends of the period.
OK.
That is just a
simple introduction
to the symmetry properties.
We have also as we've
talked about with
our other transforms,
the convolution property.
And the convolution property
relates very heavily
to the type of
convolution that we
were talking about for the
discrete Fourier series.
What we want to ask is, what
is the sequence, finite length
sequence x3 of n, whose
discrete Fourier transform is
the product of the discrete
Fourier transform of x1 of n,
and the discrete Fourier
transform of x2 of n.
Well, we know what the sequence
is, the periodic sequence is,
whose discrete Fourier
series is the product
of the discrete Fourier series
of the periodic equivalent
of x1 of n and the periodic
equivalent of x2 of n.
And this sequence
must just simply
be one period extracted
from x3 tilde of n.
In other words, x3 of n is equal
to x3 tilde of n multiplied
by a rectangular sequence.
Well, we know how to form
from the last lecture,
the convolution that
corresponds to multiplying
the discrete Fourier
series together.
And that convolution was the
periodic sequences x1 tilde
of m and x2 tilde of
n minus m, summed over
one period that is from m
equals 0 to capital N minus 1.
Well, the finite
length sequence,
x3 of n that corresponds
to the product of these two
discrete Fourier
transforms, corresponds then
to extracting a single period
from this periodic sequence,
in other words, multiplying
this by R sub capital N of n.
So this then is the
kind of convolution
that results from multiplying
the discrete Fourier
transforms together, or we could
write this in a different way.
We can express this
periodic sequence
using our modular notation
in terms of x1 of m,
as x1 of m taken
modulo capital N.
And this periodic sequence
is x2 of n minus m
that argument taken
modulo capital N.
Well, we can take one
additional step here,
which may or may not be useful.
Observe that we
only use values of m
in this expression in
the interval from 0
to capital N minus 1.
So in fact, although this
is a periodic sequence,
we're only using
one period of it.
So this piece is
equivalently x1 of m.
And what is this?
Well, think back to the
kind of circular shifting
that we were talking about doing
with finite length sequences.
What this basically
corresponds to doing
is applying not a
linear shift to x2 of n,
but a circular shift,
flipping x2 and applying
a circular shift to x2 of n.
And then of course,
this is just in here
to allow us to extract
a single period.
This then corresponds
to what we'll
refer to as a circular
convolution of this sequence,
or rather the sequence x1 of n,
and the finite length sequence
x2 of n.
It's a circular convolution.
And notationally we'll
denote that as x1
of n, circularly
convolved, keeping
track of what the
circumference of this cylinder
is that we're wrapping the
finite-length sequences around,
circularly convolved, an
endpoint circular convolution
with x2 of n.
Now, I wouldn't
expect at this point
that what this circular
convolution is in detail,
I wouldn't expect
that to be very clear.
We have some modular
notation in there,
and we're multiplying by this.
And there was some periodic
something somewhere,
and where did we
extract the period.
A lot of our attention
at this point,
and in fact through most
of the next lecture,
is going to be focused on
interpreting and getting
a feeling for what the
circular convolution means.
There are lots of
pictures that I'll
try to suggest to
help in forming
an idea of circular convolution.
Let me just offer
one now and show you
a simple example of circular
convolution, with the notion
that in the next lecture we'll
be focusing almost entirely
on what circular
convolution means
in relation to linear
convolution, et cetera.
But look.
Here's what this means.
First of all, linear
convolution, what do we do?
We have two sequences.
They're laid out flat.
We do a linear convolution by
flipping one of the sequences,
and then shifting the
two sequences linearly
with relation to each
other, multiplying
and adding up the values
from minus infinity
to plus infinity.
The circular
convolution basically
corresponds to wrapping
one of the sequences
around the circumference
of a cylinder,
taking the other sequence,
flipping it, wrapping
that around the circumference
of another cylinder,
putting the two cylinders
inside each other,
and then the shifting as
we change the value of n
can be thought of as
rotating one of the cylinders
inside the other, multiplying
the sequence values together,
and then adding that
product around the cylinder.
That is adding from m equals
0 to capital N minus 1.
And what this thing
does basically,
since it extracts one period
of a periodic sequence,
it corresponds
essentially to just simply
cutting the cylinder and laying
the answer around flat again.
That's the notion of
circular convolution,
and it results from
the fact that we're
thinking of the arguments
in the convolution taken
modulo capital N.
Well, let's just look at a
simple example with the idea
that as we go on to
the next lecture,
we'll be concentrating some more
on the interpretation of what
circular convolution means.
All right.
Here we have a sequence x1 of m.
Remember that in the
circular convolution,
we're summing over an index m.
So here we have x1 of m.
Here we have x2 of m.
And what we want to form
is x2 of n minus m taken
modulo capital N.
So first of all,
here we have x2 of minus
m, modulo capital N.
And what that corresponds
to is flipping x2 of m,
flipping it over, and then
repeating it periodically.
And the periodic replicas
I've designated here
with dashed lines, so
that we focus completely
on the interval 0 to
capital N minus 1.
So in fact, notice that
we could have thought
of flipping this modulo
capital N by first flipping
it, and then taking
the values over here,
and just simply replacing
them on the right-hand side.
In other words, it's these
values that ended up over here.
When we flip this sequence,
of course, the value at 0
stays where it is, and the
rest of those values end
up again in the range
0 to capital N minus 1,
but flipped over.
If we shift this
periodic sequence
by one value to the left,
then what we have is--
sorry, shift it by one
value to the right,
then we end up with
this periodic sequence.
Again, concentrate on the
range 0 to capital N minus 1,
and you can see that
that is a circular shift
of one point of one period
of this periodic sequence.
In other words,
if you circularly
shift this to the
right, that point
comes back in on the other side.
Here is the same thing shifted.
Again, another point,
so we can think
of having taken this one period,
shifting it to the right,
and this point comes back
in again on the other side.
Of course, the way we're
really getting it is--
or another way to
think of it is--
it's the corresponding value
from the next period over that
gets shifted in.
But I'd prefer
now that you begin
thinking of it as a circular
shift of just that one period.
So, you can see
that as we continue
changing the value of
n, then this one period
gets circularly shifted.
This value will
end up over here,
then this value will end
up over here, et cetera.
Well, if we carry out the
convolution of x1 of m and x2
of m, for example for
little n equals 1,
we take this,
multiply it by that,
and sum up the values in the
range 0 to capital N minus 1.
Similarly for little
n equals 2, we
take this and
multiply it by that,
sum up the values in
the product in the range
0 to capital N minus 1.
One thing that you should be
able to see in this example
is that the answer will
look quite a bit different
than a linear
convolution of these two,
because in fact, notice that
we're multiplying always by--
let's call this amplitude 1.
We're multiplying always by 1.
And no matter how we circularly
shifted this one period,
each value would still get
multiplied by the same amount.
And consequently, the resulting
values in the convolution
will be the sum of these values
no matter how much circular
shifting that we do.
So that for this particular
example, the convolution
comes out to look like this.
That is the values
in the convolution
are constant over the range
0 to capital N minus 1.
Then of course, we had this
either cutting the cylinder,
if you want to look
at it that way,
or multiplying it by
R sub capital N of n,
and consequently we get
0 outside that range.
All right.
Well, what I would
hope at this point,
I would certainly
expect that the idea
of circular convolution
isn't totally clear.
I would expect that a
little bit of the notion
is coming out of the haze.
That is the notion that things
are being shifted circularly
to implement the convolution.
That's the kind of
idea that I would hope
is becoming somewhat clearer.
And in the next lecture, what
I intend to focus on entirely
is the additional interpretation
of circular convolution,
with the hope that by the
end of the next lecture
the notions of the circular
shifting and the difference
between circular convolution
and linear convolution
will be clear.
Thank you.